Speaker 1: All right, so it's been mostly,
you know, kind of a serious downer of a show
today in some sense, I want to go through
a couple of things that are a little bit lighter,
although not particularly less disturbing,
I guess, depending on your perspective about
the types of people that are or have been
in prominent positions of power.
You may remember Donald Trump's former press
secretary, Kayleigh McEnany.
She was one of Trump's many press secretaries.
And one of the things that happened on the
first day that she addressed or answered questions
in the press briefing room was that she said
she was never going to lie to the press corps.
She was asked, will you tell us today you
will not lie to us?
And she said, no, I will not.
And of course, almost exclusively, she lied
for Donald Trump day after day after day.
She recently spoke at a Turning Point USA
event.
It was a really strange event, but the highlight
was her saying she never did lie as the White
House press secretary.
And it was because of her faith and because
of God that she didn't lie.
This you have to see.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: And then there was the question,
will you ever lie to us?
And I said without hesitation, no, I never
did.
Speaker 1: And she certainly didn't hesitate.
But she did lie
Speaker 2: to faith as a mother, a baby Blake,
as a person who meticulously prepared and
some of the world's hardest institutions,
I never lied.
I sourced my infant.
Speaker 1: Nobody who went to Harvard ever
lies.
Right?
I mean, that that's no no religious person
or Harvard graduate would ever tell an untruth
nation.
Speaker 2: But that will never stop the press
from calling you a liar.
Speaker 1: Also, lying will make it so that
people call you a liar.
Speaker 2: Which is why my dad said, Kaylie,
you've got to come up with a motto for your
press shop, and I did.
And our motto was this all sense only because.
Wow, because I knew what we were up against,
Republicans always get the bad headlines,
always get the false stories, always get the
lies.
If I can use that word told by the press,
there is one standard for Democrats and another
for Republicans.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, OK, so basically she she wants
us to believe she never told a lie at all
while she was Donald Trump's White House press
secretary.
I actually it's almost everything is backwards.
I have a hard time remembering a more dishonest
press secretary.
I don't know who it would be if he said who
was a more dishonest press secretary than
Kayleigh McEnany.
I don't know that I can think of one.
Here is Kailee, just as a few examples telling
us covid affects virtually nobody.
Remember this gem.
Speaker 2: Following last night, the president
said at one of his rallies about the virus
and I think he was talking about younger Americans.
He said it affects virtually nobody, by the
way, over your schools, everybody open your
schools.
But he said to Bob Woodward, it's not just
old.
It's not just older people.
It's young people to about 200000 deaths.
Shouldn't the president be telling people
the truth about this virus at his rallies?
The president is telling people the truth.
And you're right, Jim, that he was talking
about saying that it affects virtually nobody
and that it doesn't affect young people.
He's not telling the truth.
Those are here, again, taking the president
out of context.
I had his full quote here.
And you're right that he was referring to
young people.
He said this was taken out of context.
And I said he was talking about younger people
Speaker 1: quoting someone and explaining
what the context was, is not taking someone
out of context.
That's true.
Speaker 2: I'm taking here you are taking
it out of context because you're making an
assertion that he's not giving critical information
when in fact, he is.
And I will underscore exactly what he says.
OK, so
Speaker 1: complete and total liar all the
time.
Here's another one where Caylee says Trump
never downplayed the virus, even though Trump
told Bob Woodward, I publicly downplayed the
virus.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: Because I don't want to create
a panic.
The president, by his own admission in private,
on the record, acknowledge the depth of this
crisis and yet told the American people something
very different right now is that at its core,
not an abject betrayal of the public trust.
The president has always been clear eyed with
the American people.
He's always clear eyed about the lives we
can lose.
Speaker 1: Yeah, like when he said the lives
we could lose are we have 15 cases, which
will soon be zero.
He was really clear with the American people
about the hell that was coming
Speaker 2: on again from this podium.
He acknowledged that this was serious back
in March, that a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand lives could be lost next week.
Speaker 1: Now, remember back, that's a lie.
In March, he was saying, I don't even know
if it was March.
Even by April, he was still only saying we
might lose 50000 people.
I mean, it was all just lie after lie after
lie.
Here she is saying Trump is the most informed
person on the planet about threats to the
United States and the American people.
Speaker 2: The president does read it and
he also consumes intelligence verbally.
This president, I'll tell you, is the most
informed person on planet Earth when it comes
to the threats that we face.
You have Ambassador O'Brien, who sees him
in person twice a day, sometimes takes upwards
of half a dozen calls with this president.
He's constantly being informed and briefed
on intelligence matters.
But I'm not going to allow The New York Times
to dictate when we give top secret information
and don't give.
There is no
Speaker 1: more informed person, my friends,
than Donald Trump.
And then lastly, another lie from Kayleigh
McEnany, which was her participation in the
lies about the 2020 election.
She was trotted out there.
I don't remember if it was in her capacity.
I think this was her capacity as an adviser
to Trump.
You know, she had multiple different roles.
Remember this one?
Speaker 2: We want to protect the franchise
of the American people.
We want an honest, accurate, lawful count.
We want maximum sunlight.
We want maximum transparency.
We want every legal vote to be counted and
we want every illegal vote.
I just think we have to be very clear that
she's charging.
This is, by
Speaker 1: the way, when this was too dishonest,
even for Fox News.
This is a Fox host cutting in and saying this
is crazy,
Speaker 2: welcoming sign and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to back
that up.
I can't in good countenance continue this.
I want to make sure that when
Speaker 1: even Fox News says, I can't show
you this, guys, this is even making Fox News
blush.
So Kayleigh McEnany now taking credit for
never having lied.
And it is a liar lying about their lying.
That's, quite frankly, all it is.
And it shouldn't surprise us